combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de
patapouf il ne faut trop peco notez bien
sur vos trois mois dans votre retour
attention ils ont manqué
coupant tout bas c'est pas beau ça
cependant brrr bien sûr mais c'est un
aller répondait un deux montants les
jeunes savaient reconnaître les arbres
fruitiers un abricotier un pognon vous
n'y connaissez rien un arrangeur c'est
un cerisier
moi je crois que c'est un pas mieux je
te dis que j'étais cerisier
[Musique]
5h20 suis distraite
au lieu d'acheter des pommes pour mata
j'ai assez de blocs de l'aisne une tarte
à la laine c'est sûrement pas bon
j'adore les pâtes à peluches je né vois
[Musique]
pas ta vie tu avais raison
c'est un pommier en tout cas c'est un
arbre miracle j'ai planté ya une heure
et il donne déjà des fruits patins ce
truc de passe un truc c'est pas moi qui
ai trouvé ce truc tel truc le pouce
super vite à pomme à moins que 13 ans et
si c'était du plastique
je viens d'en goûter c'est une vraie pop
et quelle saveur
et
[Musique]
on voulait faire une tarte aux pommes
par de pommes pour vous faire une tarte
à laurence plus d'orange on n'y comprend
rien but
vous vous rendez compte deux récoltes
par jour
et cette fois ce sont des oranges thé
orange pourrait sûrement quelques
ouvrages dont mon bateau il n'en est pas
question
ce sont les oranges de mon arbre
[Musique]
les boîtes de conserve
c'est vraiment un arbre magique qui eux
mêmes les prix d'où les boîtes les prix
mais c'est impossible alors au volant
que vous a tant donné les pommes maison
mon aîné conservons de fruits
l'arbre de magic pad d'asus vient ici
petit visera à tu vas voir l'arbre
magique sac à papier ou est ce jeune a
pas que je lui tire les oreilles aux
états unis laisse mon arbre tranquille
des sceaux immédiatement c'est un papa
du tiers monde l'attend car si vous la
poule le finira bien par décembre
certainement pas j'ai en mange à tour
plusieurs jours
[Rires]
[Musique]
et maintenant au
croyez vous qu'il y ait de papus ne vous
trompez pas voter bien sûr faut trois
heures à 12 heures il manque
[Musique]